hi I'm Eric CEO of chess comm and this
week I was inspired by the revelation of
the New World Chess Championship logo to
be held this year next year in London
yeah I was too he sent me the photo
right away when it came out and I was
like this is this is brilliant this is
the best thing for chess and since
probably deep blue yeah this is huge
it's gonna it's gonna blow up worldwide
we love what they've done with the logo
I think it's gonna really attract the
masses
I've always felt that chest was a very
connecting game a way to get two people
together kind of very intimately on the
chess board connection of ideas
connection of Mines connections of
emotions and I really thought that this
logo kind of embodied that vision yeah
so with that we're gonna do a photo
shoot kind of to try and capture this to
really see and feel for each of us you
know how this was Jay and I were
roommates in college so this is you know
not completely uncomfortable for us
right we would play in our dorm room
floor all the time and it wasn't unusual
for us to engage like this yeah anyway
we think bring it to life it was it was
proper homage to the to the image here
so close already at each other yeah
sorry anyway let's try and play a quick
game right yeah okay okay well let's do
it
fair okay which one left hint I guess
that won't work okay okay you just play
okay that's already in front of me
okay I feel like you've played this I'm
gonna play g6 I'm gonna say the board
feels heavy I hope he's got a lighter
version let me press it on my knee
simply get a little closer I can rest on
my knee okay perfect
your turn I think they should adopt this
in tournament play no joke
I think for World Championship it's may
be appropriate but I think right general
I mean play this interesting move Knight
h6 okay I think you know most of the top
players who are gonna be in the event
they know each other pretty well they
probably feel comfortable with this but
if you get her like a normal chess
tournament I don't know that you're
gonna feel totally comfortable I agree
and I think that high G may become more
important with the game because I mean
you might not flows for but you know the
top players they look nice they've got
you know suits on they're prepared for
this type of thing okay when is our
first water break oh I am I so hot in
here I know this is it's warm kind of
warm up here but it's also kind of
really warm
yeah you know your leg I'm having my
legs actually quite hot yeah okay okay
I'm kind of seeing the kingside you're
kind of seeing the queenside work that's
right here a little bit all right I
think I'm cramping I think I'm cramping
okay I've been right here okay wrap it
up yep
okay good good okay your knees running
out of room okay you get the shakes I'm
also getting shaky okay I don't know how
you're gonna play a full six hour game
like well you got to play faster I think
you got time management super important
this this like Kama Sutra chess okay
okay oh man
the burn I'm really starting to burn
time fire
okay okay I think you got the pawn here
I I know it feels like that but I want
to oh your your your queens hanging but
it's I'm actually falling back okay I'm
falling back I resigned I don't guess
I'm a great king okay yeah good game
okay okay so I think what we learned
from this is that's good I mean I feel
like I know you better than just players
yeah yeah for sure
um I've actually feel when you were
getting intimidated insert some of the
positions there yeah I can really feel
it I can feel what you were excited
about your position you know that yeah
okay anyway this has been fun for us
think it's um you know bringing in a new
generation of chess I think sometimes
the digital chest is separating people
two screens across from the planet this
is a great way to bring people back
together with the you know fit you know
facing each other on the board next to
each other you know playing a game of
chess I really agree I want to finish
this out of the hug yeah anyway again if
you want to watch the coverage the World
Championship next year in London
follow us on chess calm thank you